c'est l'histoire d'un australien de 80
ans qui est la sensation de vivre chaque
jour la même journée
British Medical Journal il a développé
un syndrome rare qu'on appelle le
syndrome du dgcu Wiz recollectif
confabulation qui lui donne l'impression
de vivre chaque jour la même journée en
boucle les premières chaleurs estivales
qui arrivent sur l'hexagone forcément un
casse-tête sur les chantiers ce qui ne
travaille pas aujourd'hui ont un peu
plus de chance mais pour eux aussi l'été
se fait déjà sentir voyons les mêmes
informations tous les jours à la
télévision et bien c'est australien a
décidé de ramener la télévision chez le
réparateur pensant qu'il y avait un
problème et que ça ne viendrait pas de
son propre cerveau mais contrairement
aux déjà vu qu'on peut tous avoir un
jour cette récurrence chez cet homme est
lié à la maladie d'Alzheimer pas mal de
chaleur c'est cette semaine avec des
températures assez chaudes une
atmosphère assez tout fente
en terrasse et à l'ombre voilà j'aime
tellement les Big Mac c'est terrible que
je dois dire que quand j'attendais alors
maintenant j'en mange moins mais quand
j'attendais mon premier enfant je ne
voulais pas de fraise je voulais des Big
Mac à 16h à 16h j'allais m'asseoir
enceinte jusqu'au cou au McDo j'avais
tellement honte mais c'était si bon et
vous m'avez dit dans un message je cite
je suis très fier de servir à quelque
chose alors que notre métier et si
décrié bah oui
[Rires]
des passionnés ont mis un an et demi
pour le construire une précision une
rectification la semaine dernière j'ai
cité le nom de Jean-Pierre Chevènement
parmi les bénéficiaires du régime
complémentaire de retraite des députés
européens alors qu'il s'agissait de
Jean-Pierre Raffarin je vous le présente
toutes mes excuses pour cette erreur la
différence vis-à-vis des médias et de
plus en plus forte parce que je sais pas
il y a mille causes et mille
conséquences les voilà les gens
préfèrent s'informer sur Youtube
ou sur cnews
ça c'est fait
réponds aussitôt en moins de 20 secondes
chrono
[Musique]
m'attendez on est protégé et au voleur
on dit ciao on dit ciao ciao c'est
aussitôt en moins de 20 secondes chrono
et le cambrioleur le cambrioleur il va
être représenté vous allez voir le
cambrioleur est blanc quoi
cambrioleur blanc mais non mais c'est
impossible il y a un truc qui ne va pas
dans le scénario alors si on le
représente avec par exemple un jeune
issu pourquoi pas des quartiers ça peut
arriver oui mais là on va dire attention
donc on met un vieux monsieur c'est pas
le profit généralement numéro un des
voleurs avec une moustache qui lui
manque juste le béret basque si tu veux
pour dire que c'est un mal blanc de 65
ans que la partie de pétanque ça fait
plaisir la boule paraissent planque
comme ma loisir tu l'as visé tu la
manque change ton pire une partie de
pétanque ça fait plaisir on adore une
famille française je le dis aujourd'hui
qui représentait elle ne peut plus être
blanche
mais la pub elle est le reflet de la vie
elle refait
de la vie rêvé par certains pardon on va
remarquer une pause on parlera du
Maréchal Pétain dans quelques secondes
et Jean-Marie Le Pen entre dans ce
vestibule où j'étais se dirige vers moi
et me tend la main
et là j'ai eu une seconde pour me dire
qu'est-ce que je fais parce que il y a
25 ans serrer la main de Jean-Marie Le
Pen c'était quelque chose d'inimaginable
et la dernière mot que m'a dit à cette
femme Sylvie en partant elle a dit mazel
tov et vous le direz lundi je dis oui
alors mazel tov Jérémy alors je me suis
dit que j'allais qui se serait pire de
me faire engueuler par mon rédacteur en
chef donc je lui essai à la main
aujourd'hui ces questions là sont un peu
désuètes
et enfin on va prendre la direction du
Japon pour terminer ce journal ou des
étudiants réapprennent ta sourire après
la pandémie de covid regardez ces images
après avoir porté le masque pendant
plusieurs mois et bien beaucoup n'y
arrivent plus alors l'entreprise smile
education donne des cours à l'Institut
d'Art de Tokyo et c'est grâce à un
détecteur facial que le sourire des
étudiants est évalué sur une note de
sang et figurez-vous qu'une séance
privée coûte environ 50 euros plus que
ces problèmes de coeur l'homme est en
boucle sur les gestes barrières mises en
place depuis la crise sanitaire
et ils vont me dire me casser les
couilles et nous mettre un coton-tige
dans le nez toutes les 20 minutes il va
me casser les couilles donc au bout d'un
moment il faut qu'ils arrêtent aussi
d'emmerder le monde avec leur de
coton-tige
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si jamais vous vous rappelez plus des
chiffres vous chanter baby Shark parce
que Baby Shark c'est le bon rythme pour
faire le massage cardiaque un homme sur
8 prend des préservatifs à un
enterrement
les gars font un enterrement ils
prennent des préservatifs au cas où
c'est incroyable
parce que c'est l'ultime lieu de de de
mentalité c'est des gens sont tristes
ils ont besoin de c'est pour profiter
des
très bonne idée en fait les événements
dramatiques ça booste la libido ce qu'on
a un manque à combler ensuite il y a
plein de meufs à consoler souvent dans
les enterrements
avec les lunettes de soleil tu peux
mater des boules discrètement
[Musique]
maintenant une actrice française qu'on
ne présente plus beaucoup de son cul et
pourquoi je vous confirme j'ai envie de
vous dire que ils sont clairement
tellement beaucoup de ces films sont
cultes
[Musique]
à la cuisson
le partage c'est que du bonheur
[Musique]